un carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
un gusto saludarles desde parís
bienvenidos a este espacio donde la
cultura es noticia hoy los invitamos a
un viaje por la prehistoria pero también
por la ópera el cine y la música
esto es carrusel de las artes
el hombre de neandertal y homo sapiens
reunidos a través del dibujo es lo que
propone el autor francés nicolas en at
con su álbum de historietas megafauna
cómo se fabrica un espectáculo de ópera
fuimos a la ciudad de galeón para
descubrir la fábrica ópera un colectivo
que hace accesible el arte lírico para
todos los públicos
en los estrenos de cine un drama
apasionado y una comedia negra
franco-belga llegan a las salas oscuras
y en nuestra crónica musical iremos al
encuentro de un cantante que no tiene
miedo de expresar sus sentimientos se
llama danny tejera y su bandera es la
sinceridad
a
comenzamos este programa con una
historieta francesa que nos plantea un
encuentro entre dos especies humanas
megafauna es un relato de aventura y de
fantasía pero que también nos hace
reflexionar sobre la aceptación y el
entendimiento entre los seres humanos y
su autor converso con nosotros
qué pasaría si el hombre de neandertal
no hubiera desaparecido de la faz de la
tierra y conviviera con homo sapiens esa
es la hipótesis que plantea megafauna
historieta del francés nicolas de nat
megafauna relata el viaje de dos amigos
médicos al reino de neandertal un pueblo
de aspecto primitivo y burdo
atrincherado detrás de una muralla pero
cuyas riquezas son codiciadas por los
sapiens
a mí siempre me interesó este momento de
la humanidad cuando hubo un en un
encuentro misterioso porque no sabemos
mucho de lo que pasó hace tantos siglos
entre dos seres humanos muy parecidos
pero a la vez con muchas diferencias que
podemos imaginar cómo vivirían los
neandertales en la edad media' y eso
siempre me interesó también me interesó
otro momento de la historia de la
humanidad que es cuando los sapiens
fueron américa y se encontraron con la
otra parte desafiadas que no se habían
visto desde 15 mil o 16 mil años y en
realidad mi historia es un poco una
mezcla de esto porque los sapiens van a
descubrir un mundo varios desata mena
nuevo porque casi nunca lo vieron ya que
está al otro lado de esta muralla
gigante
con este relato nicola fluyen al habla
del temor que genera lo que no se conoce
pero también de atreverse a mirar lo
desconocido
los protagonistas son dos chicos sapiens
jóvenes médicos que están enviados de
manera casi diplomática para entender
por qué los enormes se llaman los north
entre los neandertales cerraron del todo
zamora ya no hay más intercambio
comercial lo cual necesitaban los aliens
y esos dos chicos con una mirada un poco
ingenua se descubre todo este mundo
muchas sorpresas peligro aventura y
también es una historia iniciática
porque son muy jóvenes y van aprendiendo
la vida de manera muy brutal
[Música]
en este cuento filosófico prd en ata
puso algo de lo que fue en su propia
experiencia al descubrir américa latina'
yo viví en américa unos años y creo que
no tuve la misma experiencia que mis
protagonistas porque ellos están muy
asustados y todo es tan diferente pero
américa latina es de cierta manera para
mi otra casa obviamente somos de la
misma especie no entonces no no tuve las
mismas sensaciones pero es verdad que
descubrir otro mundo otras maneras de
vivir siempre enriquece los viajes no
nos nutren un montón y nos dan muchas
cosas muchas cosas que contar también
muchas historias que vivimos cuando
viajamos
[Música]
carrusel de las artes los lleva ahora a
la ciudad francesa de orleans donde una
asociación trabaja para popularizar la
ópera creando espectáculos en los que
participan aficionados y estudiantes
locales melissa barra nos presenta la
afa wake o pegado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las voces de un puro llenando el
escenario pero aquí no cantan sopranos o
tenores de fama mundial
[Música]
la fábrica de ópera de balde uruguay con
el 'sí' en espectáculos líricos o
modernos cooperativos es decir que el
equipo lo constituyen artistas y
voluntarios locales y las funciones se
realizan no en el teatro de la ópera sin
en salas populares
[Música]
clemons huber director artístico y
director de orquesta
[Música]
se trata de un trabajo colectivo hay
cientos de jóvenes así como voluntarios
aficionados que forman parte del coro
además hay 150 profesionales en el
escenario
profesional
[Música]
el objetivo es que la gente se anime a
existir a un espectáculo de arte lírico
[Música]
este año la fábrica ópera presenta su
versión del musical 'west side story'
[Música]
el decorado los vestidos y los peinados
son obra de 650 estudiantes de la región
como lean a alumna del liceo profesional
de costura de óleo
efe
tuvimos que realizar hasta seis metros
de dobladillos un trabajo larguísimo
pero aprendimos a hacerlo de forma
rápida y minuciosa
[Música]
miles de niños de todas las edades
asisten a estas funciones e incluso a
los ensayos
[Música]
pues side story' ha sido visto por unos
13.000 espectadores
y a continuación los estrenos del cine
francés esta semana salen en las salas
dos películas llenas de color y
sentimientos amor y burlesque
[Música]
el multipremiado director and show son
regresa a las pantallas con peter fong
can't una cinta en homenaje al cineasta
alemán ya fallecido rainer werner
fassbinder peter font kan es un exitoso
director de cine que se prenda de amor
por el joven amigo
este drama sentimental lleno de música y
de unos colores que podrían recordar a
un cierto almodóvar trata de la pasión
que traspasa las fronteras sociales o de
edad peter fong cant cuenta con la
actuación espectacular de isabelle
adjani y del actor don y menos
arrebatado de amor por su joven amante
llega también una comedia franco-belga
atrás y alocada music-hall cuenta la
historia de amor y peleas de una pareja
muy ordinaria un día francis consigue a
su esposa martín y descuartizada en el
refrigerador de su casa
comienza entonces la investigación
policial en forma de espiral infernal en
un largometraje que reivindica lo
políticamente incorrecto entre misoginia
en un centro pía y una alta dosis de
humor negro al punto que algunos
críticos la han bautizado el pool
fiction belga
no
ahora ya de nuestra crónica musical como
siempre con una tablet olivares sola
natalia hoy nos presenta es un artista
100% parisino danny tejas que acaba de
sacar un nuevo disco bastante
introspectivo pero inspirado también en
el romanticismo francés dany trabaja es
un joven productor francés de la nueva
escena pop parisina y él le reivindica
ese nuevo disco del álbum danny como
para completar su perfil artístico
cantante solista y lo fuimos a conocer
en pleno corazón de parís
sí
ya no
yo siento que formo parte de una familia
de artistas de la escena emergente
parisina interactuamos a menudo ya sea
en grabaciones en el escenario o en la
vida diaria lo bueno es que hay mucha
solidaridad no hay rivalidades y eso es
muy interesante
de cruzar
recibirle
sin más
[Música]
ella
sí
danny nos invita a un viaje
introspectivo
ese viaje hacia el interior del universo
de su personaje en base a la melancolía
no es un disco cualquiera no es un álbum
no es una ip es un mixtape y el concepto
es sacar cada 15 días una canción que
revela un poco más de ese universo de
ese personaje es un autorretrato a
cuentagotas
este disco me refleja totalmente
es más ese mixtape soy yo es muy
autobiográfico danny te ahoga no es un
personaje y eso es lo increíble parece
como el nombre de un personaje de
ficción pero es real soy yo assange
[Música]
alta
acá
tenemos aquí un verdadero crooner
parisino de los tiempos modernos él
reivindica esa melancolía a la francesa
de su lado el poeta maldito como lo
diría por ejemplo los poetas
también
evocar a baudelaire y esa estética de la
melancolía y del spring francés para mí
es un cumplido
siento que refleja esa tendencia sobre
todo la canción y el mundo en la cual
quiere utilizar esa imagen muy francesa
típicamente parís y el vídeo es una
referencia a las películas de los años
60 si quisiera exportar mi música al
extranjero lo haría con ese mensaje de
salud lo blanco
y
claro
[Música]
y
un poco depresivo el personaje pero te
tengo que decir maria carolina que fue
un encuentro bien simpático le
arrancamos una sonrisa y al final
terminamos diciendo que la vida era
bella bueno mucha melancolía para danny
te agave y justamente vamos a terminar
natalia este programa con una de sus
canciones la acabamos de escuchar y de
ver bajo la lluvia el blog el mover para
terminar este carrusel de las artes
muchísimas gracias por su sintonía y
hasta la próxima jaua
[Música]
no
sí
claro
qué bien